all right which doesn't belong and why
one of our favorite segments here where
we go through three things and we have
to come up with which one doesn't fit
and the last time we did it it gave me
mental fits trying to figure out which
doesn't belong and why
here we go bill belichick coaching
disciples joe judge brian flores
matt patricia which doesn't belong and
why well the one that stands out to me
is joe
judge just because uh two reasons
one he's not a coordinator like
patrician flores were
right they were you know de facto
coordinators i don't know if flores ever
got the official
job title there but that's what he was
and of course joe judge hasn't coached
an nfl game yet so he's still
you know a rookie as far as that's
concerned so i think that's why
i would say he doesn't belong in this
conversation brian flores doing some
good things down there in miami they're
building something
big year for matt patricia we don't know
what to expect from joe judge yet we
know nothing about him i've liked what
you know how he's handled his team and
and the way he comes off in front of the
media and all that stuff i've been
impressed
uh but yeah he's the one that jumps out
to me what about you mike to me it's
flores flores is the man genius of the
bunch he's the one who stayed in the
division and stuck his finger in the eye
of bill belichick
and it's amazing right right i mean and
look it
it was fine last year because the
dolphins stunk right
but if the dolphins turn into something
there's gonna be a little problem there
and i'm surprised there hasn't been a
problem yet because we know how big of a
deal it was when eric mangini defected
for the jets now maybe it's because it
was the jets
and not the bills or the dolphins
because there's that that just
thing between the jets and the patriots
and belichick and the jets
but yep you you leave bill belichick you
leave the division and ideally you leave
the conference like joe judge and matt
patricia did
so flores i respect him for staying in
the division
and dealing with belichick twice per
year because i think these other guys
just don't want to have anything to do
with it well yeah to your point i mean
you know to what you're saying he he
cost the patriots a buy last year in the
playoffs with that week 17 win and all
that so
he's already you know given bill a
little bit of a headache or something to
think about here going in the future so
i hear you that was a good one i like
that what's next
all right next one which doesn't belong
and why leonard fournette le'veon bell
todd gurley oh i'm going to say leonard
fournette doesn't
it doesn't belong i mean one he's not on
a team like the other two are right now
but the other thing is
to me leonard fournette has nothing to
prove as a player like
i know where he's at he's in the prime
of his career
le'veon bell i don't know where the hell
he is right now i don't know if he's
anywhere near
being justified being able to justify
over 13 million dollars a year at the
running back position
you know we've talked to uh you know
yesterday it's
he didn't play great last year and i
know it wasn't a lot of help around him
but didn't play any football the year
before so where's he at
and then todd gurley i think the same
question you know you could ask just
has he passed his prime i i mean more
than likely i would say yes
and i think he has something to prove
too to show that hey
i'm not totally done here i got a few
years left i could still be dangerous
and break a long one down the sidelines
uh so to me those two guys have
something to prove where leonard
fournette
uh has nothing to prove physically on
the field to me at this point
to me it's todd gurley just because and
i hate to say it because i know it
upsets him
he doesn't like it coming up he doesn't
want to have bad karma on his knee
but it's been a common theme now for a
long time
the knee is a problem he's not the same
player that he was because of the knee
he's got that clear physical limitation
that is going to dog him for the rest of
his career the questions are going to
come up in atlanta no matter how well he
does
he can have 1500 rushing yards and we're
going to get to the end of the season
and if he has 1500 yards clearly they're
going to be in the postseason
conversation and the questions are going
to be how's the knee house in the house
the knee
and we're always going to be waiting for
that moment where he can't play because
of the knee
that's what separates him from the other
two all right how about number one
receivers in uncertain quarterback
situations
alan robinson of chicago keenan allen of
the chargers terry mclaren of washington
which doesn't belong and why i'm going
to go with terry mclaurin
first off because his quarterback is
really got
very very limited experience i mean alan
robinson is going to have folger
trubisky
i mean trubisky's played in the playoffs
keenan allen of course tyrod
taylor he's played in a playoff game too
and been around mccoran's you know
coming he's young and
coming up with a young quarterback also
he's a different player than
the other two keenan allen and alan
robinson are possession receivers good
route runners
terry mclaren has three rockets up his
butt he is tyree kill
he is that kind of guy he is take the
top off a defense speed sweep around the
edge for 70.
he has special special game breaking
type speed that's why i say he doesn't
belong
yeah and i'm gonna say terry mclaren
just because i feel like there's so much
unwritten with him we have an idea of
who alan robinson is we have an idea of
who keenan allen is
tara mclaren comes out and has this
great season amid
just a bunch of dysfunction in
washington how good can he be there's a
fascination
with terry mclaren that there isn't with
the other guys because they've been
around
he's still got that that that that new
car smell yeah right right so a new shot
right right hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports